Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute
Papers with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
You can immediately start holding on to your
papers, because today we are going to take
a journey around the globe and simulate the
weather over the mountainous coast of Yucatan,
a beautiful day in the Swiss Alps, and
a searing day in the Sahara desert.
Yes, from now on all of this is possible
through the power of this new paper. Just
to showcase how quickly things are improving
in the wondrous land of computer graphics,
first, we were able to simulate a
tree. And then, researchers learned
to then simulate an entire forest. But
that’s not all, then, more recent papers
explore simulating an entire ecosystem for
thousands of years. Now that’s something.
So, are we done here? What else is there to do?
Well, this new work finally helps us simulating
weatherscapes, and it can go from
a light rain to a huge snowstorm.
Now, previous methods were also
able to do something like this,
but something was missing. For instance,
here, this looks great, but, the buoyancy part
is just not there. Why? Well, let’s look at
the new method and find out together! Yes,
the new work simulates the microphysics of
water, which helps modeling phase changes and
buoyancy properly. You are seeing the buoyancy
part here. That makes a great difference.
So, what about phase changes? Well,
look at this simulation. This is also
missing something. What is it missing? Well, the
simulation of the Foehn effect! What this means is
a phenomenon where condensed warm air approaches
one side of the mountain, and something happens…or
to be more exact, something doesn’t happen.
In reality, this should not get through.
So, let’s see the new simulation! Oh yes!
It is indeed stuck. Now that’s what I call
a proper simulation of heat
transfer and phase changes. Bravo.
And here you also see another example of a proper
phase change simulation see where the rainwater
flows down the mountain to the ground, and the
new system simulates how it evaporates, wait for
it…yes! It starts to form new clouds! So good.
And it can simulate many more amazing
natural phenomena beyond these in a way
that resembles reality quite well. My
favorites here are the mammatus clouds,
a phenomenon where the air descends and
warms, creating differences in temperatures
in the cloud, and this is what the
instability it creates looks like,
and, oh my! The hole punch! This can emerge due
to the air cooling rapidly, often due to a passing
aircraft. All of these phenomena require the
simulations of the microphysics of water. Bravo!
So, microphysics huh? That
sounds computationally expensive,
so, let’s pop the question - how long do we have
to wait for a simulation like this? Are you seeing
what I am seeing? How is that even possible? This
runs easily interactively, with approximately
10 frames per second. It simulates this
and this and all of these variables
and it can do all this ten times every
second? That is insanity. Sign me up!
Now, one more thing. Views are not everything. Not
even close. However, I couldn’t ignore the fact
that as of the making of this video
only approximately 500 people watched
the original paper video. I think that this is
such a beautiful work, everyone has to see it.
Before Two Minute Papers, I was just running
around at the university with these papers in
my hand trying to show them to the people I know.
And today, this is why Two Minute Papers exists,
and it can only exist with such an amazing and
receptive audience as you are. So thank you so
much for coming with us on this glorious journey,
and make sure to subscribe and hit the bell icon
if you wish to see more outstanding works like
this, we have a great deal more coming up for you.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!